given the typically inclement conditions
the country enjoys most of the Year
you'd think the UK wouldn't have a
problem with water it might not grow on
trees but it does fall from the skies
with alarming regularity and yet raw
sewage is dumped into our rivers and
seas with even greater frequency in 2022
on average
824 times a day that is but where
there's muck there's brass and since
privatization in 1989 water firms have
paid 66 billion pounds in dividends so
why then is the country's largest
supplier Thames water on the brink of
collapse it's not just that it's 14
billion pounds in debt nor that every
day it leaks the equivalent of 250
Olympic-sized swimming pools from its
pipes and its by no means the only Farm
in trouble according to the industry
water bills may need to rise by as much
as 40 sent to pay for the much needed
improvements to infrastructure
that's despite our water bills Rising
far faster than inflation or even toilet
paper in the Thames it's enough to drive
you to drink something other than water
I'm Neil Patterson welcome to this guy
News Daily
okay A little later I'll be speaking to
the chairman of river action a charity
that's hoping to solve the problems in
Britain's waterways but first our
business correspondent Paul Kelso Paul
look why on Earth has the country's
biggest water company 50 million
customers in London and the
southeasternal less I mean why on Earth
has it been allowed to come to the brink
of collapse
well the current management or at least
the management until earlier this week
when Sarah Bentley the chief executive
resigned without explanation triggering
this latest crisis they claim the reason
is mismanagement by previous owners who
extracted huge amounts of dividends and
placed paying out shareholders and
extracting profits above investing in
infrastructure water is perhaps the most
controversial of the privatizations
and it faces a triple challenge if you
ask private companies to run your vital
utilities you need them to invest in the
infrastructure to ensure it's improved
and most of the times you need it to
keep bills low so that customers pay a
reasonable price but they also demand a
profit so they so it is worth the
investment it's worth the private money
being put into water now that captive
Market because water is not a genuine
competitive market you can't switch your
water provider that captive Market makes
it very attractive to investors and
Thames Waters owners are a mix of
Pension funds and Sovereign wealth funds
they're drawn by that guaranteed income
but it has not been enough even though
it generates a profit it hasn't been
enough to do those three things to
service its debt to improve
infrastructure and to keep bills low the
price ultimately can charge Bill payers
is set by the regulator off what yeah
okay Paul but but Thames water
have a choice as well don't they they
didn't need to hand out the amount of
money that they did millions billions
whatever it was in terms of dividends to
their shareholders they could have
invested that I mean currently Thames
water this leakier than a porcupine's
raincoat
they are they have a they have a woeful
record on leaks to add to the appalling
Financial picture and you're right they
didn't have a choice but the the tacit
deal with a privatized water system
which the UK or England should say it's
just England has had since 1989 is that
if you were going to allow private
companies to run your utilities to even
own the infrastructure the argument is
they will be out they'll run the run it
better than the price than the public
sector they'll generate money for
investment they will be able to turn a
profit as a consequence and that is the
trade-off and it's where that balance
has fallen that has caused disquiet from
the very start of the perhaps more than
any other sector any other utility
industry because there isn't at least in
the energy industry which has been
decimated recently but there was a
market you could switch providers you
can't do that in water and Thames has
been perhaps the most egregious example
of big dividends being taken under
earlier ownerships perhaps more markedly
under than under the current one and not
investing enough in the infrastructure
which is the the other side of the
bargain the focus and this is where the
crucial player is is the regulator that
is effectively the voice of the customer
influenced by government they enforce
where that balance Falls and for many
years the focus has been on keeping
prices down there's some debate about
depends how you calculate the figures
but certainly in the last years it's
felt like one of the few bills that
hasn't been going up that's because
there is downward pressure on price and
no government wants to be announcing or
allowing customer bills to go up but
that balance is perhaps shifting when
we've seen the public reaction to the
consequence of a lack of investment
which is what has been pouring into
rivers and turning up on beaches the
kind of stuff people do not want to see
when they're out for a swim
okay let me participate in that debate
about the fact that our bills haven't
gone up considerably I mean a National
Audit office report from 2015 suggests
that since 1989 since privatization
prices have Revenue risen by 40 above
inflation you know we're looking at a
history amongst these water companies of
under investment in infrastructure of
overcharging compared to where inflation
has been sitting and now we hear that
they're going to the government cap in
hand suggesting that over the next five
years we might all need to see our water
bills going up by 25 30 40 percent
yeah and that that Nao report is perhaps
the biggest corrective to the the
argument in favor of privatizing which
is we didn't keep bills down relative
certainly uh relative to inflation they
went up they have been flatter more
recently and that is that is that is
forced sub for some of the water
companies they would say to increase
their uh Reliance on debt it's the only
way they've been able to because they
can't ask the customer for any more
money without the regulator to say so
they would say the business model is is
based on debt but it's it is it is quite
hard faced with that number
um it is quite hard to make the case
that privatization has been a success
yeah just in terms of public sentiment I
mean I would suggest that part of the
reason or the main part the main part of
the reason that the public opinion has
turned against the water companies not
necessarily anything to do with the
bills but to do with that raw sewage
being put into our rivers and our seas
but I think what what perhaps is not
commonly understood is that off times
the water company days are doing that
perfectly legally explain exactly why it
is that these water companies are able
to release this sewage we have a system
that's not just leaking but it's
creaking too much of the infrastructure
most of it was built by the victorians
an absolute Miracle the sewage system in
in the UK and in England it was the it
was The Innovation that removed cholera
from daily life and it is a miracle of
engineering but for much of the
intervening hundred or more years we've
sat back with our arms folded uh
admiring it rather than doing anything
about it one of the features of that
early system is that drainage water
runoff rain and sewage is mixed in many
sewers that is fine as long as the
quantity of water flowing through them
uh is sufficient that they don't
overflow where they shouldn't the issue
we have today with many many more
customers and Britain's population is
has has increased uh hugely there is a
tipping point at which that water that
mix of water has to go somewhere
otherwise it will back up into the homes
from which some of it is coming and
that's the point of which they're
allowed certain conditions to release uh
the mix of uh sewage and rainwater into
waterways and that is disgusting look I
mean it's pretty clear that the problems
with the the infrastructure are not
necessarily limited to those living with
inside the M25 there is going to have to
be a god-awful amount of money spent
to try and upgrade things would be a
massive massive project I mean it does
look almost 100 certain doesn't it Paul
that when it comes to it when you know
we're being when someone is asked to put
their hands in their pocket it will be
once again the consumer that will pay
for all of this you are absolutely right
when it comes to meeting the cost of
infrastructure improvements customers
will pay
very recently the water industry as a
whole took what it said was an
unprecedented step and apologized for
its failures and committed to spend 10
billion pounds over the next decade on
infrastructure improvements no prizes
for guessing who's going to pay for that
customers through increased bills but 10
billion pounds if you'll forgive me is a
drop in the ocean 70 billion pounds is
what the national infrastructure
commission estimates needs to be spent
and there is that has got to be paid for
either by the taxpayer or by the
customer and this is going to mean
guaranteed higher bills for everyone for
decades to come
[Music]
one in every four liters flowing through
Thames Waters pipes is lost to leaks
other companies do struggle with
similarly ailing infrastructure and
everyone agrees that upgrades are
required there's just much less
consensus around two should ultimately
pay Charles Watson is Chairman and
founder of campaign group River action I
mean this has just been like a car crash
in slow motion unfurling over the over
over recent recent months I mean this
this is a business that is a effectively
being stripped of its its assets
previous shareholders structures have
taken all of the cash out of the
business ladened it up with almost 20
billion pounds worth of debt
um and at the same time it has got a
it's got an infrastructure that is not
fit for purpose that has not been
invested in it it leaks a quarter of its
water a year through you know resulting
in things like hose pipe bands in the
summer and at the same time almost 70
last year almost 70 000 hours worth of
raw sewage was discharged into the river
because the simply it's not fit for
purpose from what you're saying then it
would suggest that there could be other
water companies you know in a similar if
not exactly just as dire situation as
terms water that is true I mean I mean
I've all across all the water companies
they all now have I mean they've all
taken slightly different Journeys since
since the original privatization so for
example like United utilities remains
quoted on the stock market which in
theory gives it a much better access to
Capital in an emergency situation like
this but others have have gone through a
very similar Journey as Thames water
where effectively private Equity type
investment investors and the type of
Highly leveraged highly borrowed
Financial structures of private equity
for investors use have been imposed upon
them which which rather like terms water
has has left them you know overburdened
with debt and without the capital so
desperately needed to get this that you
know to get the infrastructure fit for
purpose let's focus for a second shall
we on on sewage I mean the environment
agency pointing out that last year raw
sewage was pumped into our seasoned
Rivers
1091 times averaging 824 times a day
that raw untreated sewage is being put
into our water I mean simply put why why
are these water companies doing this
well the reason they're doing it is
because their their Capital structures
should be have to have the flexibility
to invest you know huge sums of of of of
basically the the bills the money that
gets paid to them by by customers in in
bringing what is in some cases a
Victorian an Edwardian sewage system up
to up to Modern standards um and the
problem we have in this country is our
our sewage system still combines
um drainage of from from flooding from
rainfall with the sewage system so when
when when it rains there is a choice
um either the um the the system allows
the sewage to back up into people's
homes and businesses or they open the
valve basically and and let this you
know that the overwhelm system
um flow into into nature into the
environment um into into rivers onto
Beaches into into River estuaries and or
into the sea
um and and and and and the companies do
not have the financial capability to to
to make the Investments necessary to
bring these critical Services up up to
standard so at a time when the pressures
of you know more more extreme you know
climate events is really putting the
whole thing under stress aren't these
companies being fined for this why are
the fines not working or is it just
simply a case you know these water
companies are making such profits that
they can essentially Factor the fines
into their business model as a running
cost I mean this is this is
handle is
um
they're not being fined it's it's that
they've been allowed to do this this is
this is what is just extraordinary I was
you know off what the regulator it's
supposed to be there to protect the
customers to ensure that that these
water companies deliver for a fair price
uh you know an essential service both
providing our us with you know clean
water to drink um and and to take away
our our waste um and and what our foot
also does is regulate how much money how
much profit the the investors in the
water company can take away for
themselves and and clearly what has
happened is that too much money has been
stripped out of them by the investors
too much too many billions of pounds of
dividends 75 70 billion has been paid
back to to shareholders in dividends um
leaving nothing nothing to to invest in
the system does the regulator currently
have sufficient teeth to do what you're
asking them to do it says I think
everyone is now in a blind panic and I
assume the reason the CEOs attempts
water yesterday disappeared literally
disappeared in a puff of smoke is
because she has failed in her
discussions with investors to secure the
funding needed from the existing
shareholders sure but wasn't all of this
just a natural consequence of taking
water out of public ownership wasn't
this always going to happen as soon as
you introduced the free market to it as
soon as you understand that companies
are beholden first and foremost to their
shareholders where was the impetus where
was the pressure on these companies to
invest
I I you you have hit the nail on the
head I mean there's an essential service
like like the provision of water and the
removal of sewage does not lend itself
to the private sector it it it is a
utility if you go across all the major
countries in Europe none of which have
up the same problems I mean it should
take France for example I mean you know
France is going to have the river Tech
the river sen in in the center of Paris
fit for bathing quality in time for the
for the the the the the Paris Olympics
in two years time
um and you know that could compare that
with the River Thames in London you know
which will just be inconceivable and and
that is because those those essential
Services have been kept in public
ownership they've been highly regulated
highly protected if it was inevitable
that the the water industry should
remain in public ownership then then
regulation should have been like a clamp
around you know preventing it from a
situation where it could these companies
could be taken over by private Equity
type type
um invest and strips of all their cash
absolutely but but just on that point
and allow me to put my devil's advocate
Bonnet on just for a second I mean we're
in the middle of a cost of living crisis
at the moment we have the water
companies inside Downing Street inside
number 11 saying we need to see over the
next five years prices going up by 25 30
why should I as a consumer be paying
more for my water in the middle of a
cost of living crisis just so that you
and your friends can go swimming I am
being facetious yeah look um it's a
totally understandable question to ask
um
um a problem being is that they're bust
they are financially hamstrung um
because they've stripped all the money
out um that means that that is that is
the problem and and so some you know if
we want our Rivers not to have raw
sewage you know if we don't want to get
E coli when we go paddling in in our
local river which is what is happening
all over this country we normally get
sick when we go swimming off the bit off
the beach you know we don't got kids to
get severely ill for those who don't
know as much about it as you Charles
just explain exactly the problems that
can be caused by raw sewage and volume
being put into our rivers and and
obviously of course uh our seasoned and
flowing back onto our beaches from a
perspective of our ecology and and and
nature and biodiversity you know the
pollution of rivers both by sewage and
also by other sources like intensive
agriculture is a disaster it also makes
you sick you know we are now documenting
and recording all over the country huge
levels of E coli in in in in both in
rivers and for example at Blackpool
Beach we're in the middle of summer
Blackpool Beach is closed because United
utilities is it's got a broken pipe that
is discharging raw human effluent into
the sea of Blackpool Peach so you know
it is absolute this is a public health
issue as well as a an absolute disaster
from the perspective of of you know
nature and biodiversity okay Charles so
so what then has to be done what can be
done and and ultimately who should be
paying for it I think more more
considered analysis that's been done by
a number of independent bodies shows
that something like 50 billion pounds
needs to be spent in in the industry in
order in order to get it fit for purpose
it's going to take an awful long time
because because the water companies as
we can see from you know the events the
last 24 hours
um some of them are basically bankrupt
so they don't have the money to pay for
it well does it doesn't all this mean
that we're going to end up paying for it
it does
it does um or we need some really clever
people I mean there are some really
clever Minds to start thinking about it
I mean if I was if I was running
um defra what I'd be saying is Right I'd
be saying right to the water companies
we are going to full sell a quarter of
each water company to put it on the
market to to to to to to to Green
funding type invest investment companies
who will Who Could then put in the
capital now if you if you if you don't
want that to happen then you've got to
put in that capsule and something really
dramatic and decisive has to happen and
it requires government intervention and
um you know it's it's a tragedy it's an
absolute tragedy and since recording
those interviews we've learned a bit of
detail from the meeting between the
chancellor Jeremy Hunt and the industry
Watchdog off what they've promised to do
more to crack down on companies not
doing enough to help customers in need
next year they'll be publishing binding
license conditions on how to treat those
customers and ensure targeted support
let's see how that plays out my thanks
to Paul also and Charles Watson this
Edition was produced by Emery Woodhouse
with Alex Eden our editor is Daniel
weeks truly Fair foreign